ich will dass sie nicht entdecken
600.000 menschen leben in stuttgart für
einen stadtbesuch hat ihm süd aber nur
wenig zeit ihre heutige aufgabe hat mit
einem besonderen hobby der deutschen zu
tun
sucht den kleingarten kaltental
kleingarten nicht kindergarten kennt ihr
den kleinen garten kaltental
die suche ist schwieriger als gedacht
ich denke die auf gab es nicht zu
erreichen endlich kommt die drei an ihr
ziel
wer keinen eigenen garten hat kann sich
hier ein kleines grundstück mieten
eberhard baumgarten ist der zweite
vorsitzende des kleingartenvereins
kaltental nicht einmal die
kleingartenanlage kaltental
das ist er in was im großraum stuttgart
noch so gemacht wird mit gemüseanbau
haupt dann bei uns so etwas haben wir
nicht mehr geben es gibt so was
ähnliches aber wenn das nicht
kleingarten wir nennen das die
kleingartenvereine in deutschland sind
dafür bekannt dass bei ihnen viele
strenge regeln gelten wenn das gartentor
geschlossen ist ist jemand da besitzer
anwesend ist dann muss man ihnen vereint
auch meinen garten rein darf ist offen
dann darf man die karten betreiben und
wenn man freundlich fragt darf man auch
blumen pflücken oder man hilft herrn
kern bei der ernte seiner riesen
zucchini arbeiten muss man ja nicht die
neue lage
das ist wichtig und das ist auch der
sinn vom kleingarten dass man aus der
stadt heraus kommt und sich hier erholen
können was halten sie von diesen
strengen regeln
ordnung muss sein ist dieser garten nur
auf der alten menschen weil da gibt es
auch junge menschen wie ich bin
blumen und pflanzen beschäftigt in den
augenblicken großen generationswechsel
und es kommen sehr viele jugend familien
bis ihr wollen freizeit ihre freizeit
aussitzen
das ganze in ruhe machen allzu großen
straßen und auch ein bisschen obst und
gemüseanbau unserem leben verleiht
wirklich alles bio hat jetzt kommt
aufgabe zwei findet drei verstöße gegen
die vereins regeln die drei suchen also
einen baum der höher ist als fünf meter
das wäre ein regelverstoß erster fehler
gefunden jetzt kontrollieren sie die
höhe von abdeckungen für tomaten
die ist auch vorgeschrieben 60 maximal 1
meter 60
aber das hier ist ein volltreffer das
sieht so aus
jetzt sucht das team nach
vernachlässigten gärten es nicht macht
gekommen eine abmahnung von nach der
frühen morgen wurde dann gekündigt euro
liegen und pflicht da gibt es dann keine
nachlässigkeiten mehr und einfach das
unkraut rausreißen geht auch nicht
gefunden team süd geht mit drei tickets
wieder in führung und nasser findet so
viel deutsche ordnung richtig klasse es
wäre hektisch oder funktioniert ganz gut
erzählt